GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WHAT DOES ROBERT MUELLER WANT TO
ASK PRESIDENT TRUMP?
DOZENS OF QUESTIONS ARE NOW OUT
OF THE PUBLIC FOR THE WORLD TO
SEE.
QUESTIONS THAT WERE REPORTEDLY
READ TO THE PRESIDENT'S TEAM AND
THEN LINK TO THE MEDIA.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED THE LEAKS
DISGRACEFUL.
SARAH SANDERS DIRECTED QUESTIONS
FOR LEGAL TEAM EARLIER BUT HER
DEPUTY RAJ SHAH HAD THIS TO SAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW THE VERACITY OF
THE ACCURACY OF THE LEAK IF THEY
ARE ACCURATE, THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THOSE QUESTIONS
DON'T FOCUS ON THE UNDERLYING
PREMISE OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
WHICH WAS TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUE
OF COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THERE HAS BEEN OVER A YEAR OF
INVESTIGATION.
THERE'S BEEN DOZENS OF
WITNESSES, THOUSANDS, MILLIONS
PAGES OF DOCUMENTS PROVIDED.
A ZERO EVIDENCE.
NOT A SHRED OF EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> Kimberly: ALLY -- ALAN
DERSHOWITZ THINKS THERE'S A
STRATEGY DESIGNED TO TRIP UP
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THE QUESTIONS ARE INARTFULLY
DRAWN.
THEY ARE WRITTEN AS OPEN-ENDED
QUESTIONS.
THEY ARE DESIGNED TO LET HIM
RAMBLE AND TALK, AND I SUSPECT
THAT IS THE STRATEGY OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THEY BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WEAKNESS, IF
THEY WERE TO ASK HIM DIRECT,
TOUGH QUESTIONS TO WHICH HE CAN
ANSWER YES OR NO, THAT MIGHT NOT
GIVE THEM THE ADVANTAGE THEY ARE
SEEKING.
>> Kimberly: DERSHOWITZ
DISCUSSING THE STRATEGY THAT HE
THINKS IS BEING EMPLOYED.
ASK THE OPEN-ENDED QUESTION SO
HE CAN GIVE A LONG AND LENGTHY
ANSWER AND THERE MAY BE SOME
DETAILS IN THERE TO TRIP HIM UP.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK THEY ARE PROFESSIONAL
ENOUGH TO KNOW MAY BE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING.
MAYBE THEY DON'T.
NONE OF US REALLY KNOW BUT I
THINK YES, THE QUESTIONS WERE
OPEN-ENDED.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, IT'S REALLY
UNUSUAL FOR ANYONE TO BE GIVEN A
LIST, ESPECIALLY 44 OR 49
QUESTIONS, HOWEVER MANY IT WAS,
BEFOREHAND.
I COULD SEE WHY THEY ARE
OPEN-ENDED.
IF YOU STARTED PROVIDING ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WOULD WANT A
"YES" OR "NO" ANSWER TO, THEN
THAT WOULD LOOK A LITTLE WEIRD
TOO.
THIS IS A RANGE OF TOPICS THAT
WE WANT TO GO OVER WITH HIM.
MANY OF THESE COULD BE A WOLF IN
SHEEP'S CLOTHING.
I HAD A LAWYER ON THE 2:00 SHOW
TODAY.
IT COULD END UP BEING SOMETHING
WHERE YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
YOUR CLIENT DO AN INTERVIEW.
I THINK THAT'S POSSIBLY THE
STRATEGY BEHIND THE LEAK.
I DON'T THINK THIS LEAK CAME
FROM THE MUELLER TEAM.
I THINK IT CAME FROM SOMEBODY
EITHER ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEGAL
TEAM OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT CAN I GET
IT OUT THERE.
LET EVERYBODY START TALKING
ABOUT IT AND THEN EITHER, FOR
THE LAWYERS TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
MR. PRESIDENT, EVERYBODY THINKS
YOU SHOULDN'T DO AN INTERVIEW
WITH MUELLER.
TRY TO GET HIM TO AGREE.
>> Kimberly: ALL RIGHT, GREG,
HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> Greg: I THINK THE LEAK CAME
FROM "FOX & FRIENDS."
TREASURE TROVE.
WE KEEP HEARING THE PHRASE
THIS IS A TREASURE TROVE.
MAY BE.
BUT IT MIGHT BE A TREASURE TROVE
FOR REPUBLICANS BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE COUNTING ON
WINNING THE HOUSE, I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS RUSSIAN STUFF IS GOING
TO HELP YOU.
I THINK OVER TIME THIS IS
BECOMING A SQUALID DISCRETION --
DISTRACTION.
I THINK TRUMP SHOULD SAY WE WILL
ANSWER THESE THINGS IN WRITING
AND THEN BEAT PEOPLE OVER THE
HEAD WITH IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE WORLD, WHAT IS MISSING?
WHAT ARE WE NOT SAY NOW THAT WE
USED TO SEE DOING "THE FIVE"?
ISIS VIDEOS.
ALMOST EVERY WEEK WE SAW AN ISIS
VIDEO.
FOR MONTHS, WE TALKED ABOUT THE
NUCLEAR THREAT OF NORTH KOREA.
THESE ARE TWO EXISTENTIAL
THREATS MISSING FROM THE
NEWSFEED.
I DO THINK THE MEDIA IS
COMPLETELY UNPREPARED TO REPORT
TRUMP'S SUCCESSES.
THEY DON'T HAVE IT IN THEIR
TOOLBOX.
YOU HAVE TWO MAJOR THINGS
MISSING AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO REPORT, SO YOU FOCUS ON
PORNOGRAPHY AND YOUR FOCUS ON
COLLUSION.
COLLUSION WHICH IS FALLING APART
AND HAS BEEN FALLING APART.
NOW IT'S GOING TO BECOME ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION.
THEY DON'T HAVE IT IN THEIR
TOOLKIT SO THEY ARE LEFT DOING
THIS.
WHAT'S THE END RESULT?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WANT.
IF YOU IMPEACH A PRESIDENT IN
THE MIDDLE OF SOME REALLY
HISTORIC ACHIEVEMENTS, HISTORY
WILL NOT BE KIND TO YOU.
THE VOTERS WILL NOT BE KIND TO
YOU.
NO ONE WILL BE KIND TO YOU.
>> Kimberly: INTERESTING.
YOU ARE SAYING THE MEDIA HAS GOT
A VERY EMPTY BOX.
SNAP-ON TOOLS.
SNAP OFF MEDIA.